how to budget my income as a new grad in
nyc
hello i'm a recent grad starting my
career in nyc with an annual income of
104k
nice nice nice very good very good very
good 104k
nice nice first job 104k wow you're rich
after taxes i think it's five thousand
six hundred and ninety five dollars a
month
probably that's about six thousand bucks
or sixty thousand grand
i currently live with my parents and
we'll start working a month planning on
staying at two to three weeks
or two to three months maybe i don't
know maybe they should be getting paid
100k you can't write
save up before moving out i've only had
minimum wage jobs during undergraduate
before and this was my first real career
job
this is the first time actually moving
out of on my own haha
i was wondering if anyone could give me
any guidance how much money should i
save before i move out
also is 1700 to 1900 really pushing it
if i wanted to get a one bedroom
apartment for myself i'm not opposed to
having one to two roommates but i live
with other people for so long
that i truly just want to experience
living on my own i have
40k in federal student loans i'm
planning on paying it off in maybe four
to five years about 900 bucks a month
or should i suck it up and get roommates
and pay off my loans faster have more
savings thank you
all right what do we think so let's
let's break it down 104 000
and if you pay let's say what 40k
in uh type six right so 62 000 divided
by 12.
that means that they'd have about 52
hundred dollars after taxes
every month of that they want to pay
let's say 1900
in rent that brings you to 3 300.
let's say that they've got another 200
or so in utilities that's probably an
overestimation let's just say 200.
now they're down to 3 100 bucks they got
900
in student loans a month that leaves you
with 2 200
after you've only paid your rent your
utilities and your student loans
and you got 2 200 bucks basically to
live on if you've probably got
food and other things it leaves you with
about
550 per week to live on in new york city
yeah i mean the top comment was someone
basically just saying like
word for word if you have a good rapport
with your parents stay with them as long
as you can
right because that's the general ideas
like new york city's expensive i mean we
live there right so
100 000 anywhere else in the country
outside of kind of those major
uh metropolitan areas is a [ __ ] ton of
money right
but when you think about it in the
context of in new york city it's not
really
if you're making 100k if you're making
100k in some rural part of the country
you're a trillionaire
i mean yeah the quality life is just way
different but in new york city you're uh
the rent's obviously super high cost of
living food going on anything right even
if you're like on a strict budget
uh you know shopping for groceries
everything like that so i think yeah the
key when you look at stuff like this is
just what's your
what's your largest expense right and
that's clearly going to be uh rent for
him here so how can you reduce that you
can live at home you can get roommates
you can do that kind of stuff but you
have some like non-negotiables right you
got to pay your loans off you have to
eat you have to do certain things like
that
so it's how can you reduce the other
stuff and then how can you just make
more money
if you put in a lot of hours at your job
you get promoted maybe you make more
money quicker right there's only so much
saving you can do
um but it's a little deceiving right
when you look at new york city
a hundred thousand dollars it just
doesn't go as far as you might think it
does twenty two hundred dollars was
after they paid rent utilities and their
student loans right so they killed
550 if instead they spent the 1900 bucks
on their student loans they would pay
off the student loans 40 000 in debt
right they would paid off in 21 months
but if you took that 1900
they were going to spend on rent plus
the 900 that they were budgeting for
their student loans that's 2 800
and if you basically said all right
we're going to spend all 2 800
in just over one year in 14 months
they'd be out of debt so that's the key
right is like can you suck it up for a
year or 12 months and do the commute and
do it maybe things that you don't want
14 months you can be out of debt all you
have to do is
not go get that apartment live at home
it sucks whatever tell your mom
that you love that uh her cooking tell
your dad that you love his cooking
tell them that you want to go to the
movies on friday night whatever you want
to do stay at home
spend 1900 put it towards your student
loans 900 bucks you already were
budgeting put that towards your student
loans you probably could do it even
faster
because all of a sudden if you're not
having that rent
what ends up happening is you get out of
debt getting out of debt get you back to
the starting line right
yep all right what do we think in terms
of how much savings if somebody says i
don't have a great relationship with my
family i can't stay here
uh i have to move out get a roommate
yeah i mean that's that's
uh you're 22 23 years old you ain't
earned the right to
live by yourself yet yeah like go get a
roommate and save money what are you
doing
yeah i mean you get something that's
cheaper on the rent side and then you
get a roommate to split the cost with
right but like
that goes back to there's only so much
you can do to budget and save right
the key is always going to earn more
money so if you can find a different job
that pays more if you can accelerate
your career at a faster pace if you can
do something on the side to make cash
whatever it is
it's typically easier to earn more money
than it is to just budget and save with
that said though
i know a lot of kids who they always
thought that was their issue like it was
like hey like i'm
i'm behind and why am i behind because
they don't make enough and i want to
live the same lifestyle
the problem is they're money management
as well so they basically like they
would make more money and then they
would just spend more money well the key
uh his his or her best advice might be
just to get out of new york city
right like if you can find that similar
job that pays a similar amount of money
somewhere else even if it's a large city
but a smaller cost of living
it might make sense to do that the
second thing is if you're putting 900
towards your student loans that sounds
like that's probably the minimum payment
if you could basically figure out a way
to live
let's just say that you said all right
i'm going to live on 50 bucks a day
right so 300 a week give or take uh and
if i live on that 300
or so a week that would end up being
1200 so i'll give you another thousand
dollars so even if you got the apartment
even if you paid the utilities even if
you made your 900 and you said i'm gonna
live on 300
a week then you would have another
thousand bucks that you could either be
investing with paying off the debt
whatever now here's the question is
would you rather pay off the debt or
would you rather invest
in this scenario if you could get it to
the point where you were still living at
home
and you could basically put over two
thousand dollars towards the debt you
knew you could pay off in fourteen
months
i would have spent the excess cash yes
oh yeah i would make the minimum payment
you would make the minimum oh that's the
rest oh no i would definitely pay it off
but if there's no penalty if there's no
penalty for what like say you have a
minimum payment of whatever it is per
month
900 bucks yeah 900 bucks and you have an
extra thousand so you're saying
basically just get back to the starting
line zero debt as quick as possible
you could do that or you could take that
extra thousand dollars or whatever it is
and invest it in the market
right because if you think about it if
he if he gets in the market two years
earlier than he would have
say he's putting that in an ira that's
gonna compound over time it's gonna be
worth way way way more when he actually
goes to access it yeah i think we're
saying the same thing which is
if they live at home you take your 1900
bucks that you were going to spend on
rent you take your 900
you were going to pay now you got 2 800
bucks you put that towards your debt
that debt will be paid off in 14 months
that's pretty good to get 14 months out
of school and get your debt paid off i
think you're doing pretty good there
but you still would have another what
would end up being 2500
because you wouldn't be spending money
on the uh utilities and you would have
the 12 200
i was going to be left over anyways out
of that 2500
if you could figure out how to live on
basically uh let's call it 1200
300 bucks a week now you've got 1300
additional that's what you can go and
invest with right so
you basically you're paying off you know
you're gonna get be done in 14 months
get to get the hell out of the debt
but then you got a little bit extra cash
go and invest that in the market and
that's where you start get compounding
working for you by the end of the year
right you're going to have invested 15
000 or so and really kind of be starting
kind of
uh your financial journey with
five figures in the in uh in investments
that's not bad to start
hey guys thanks so much for watching
that clip of the best business show make
sure you like and subscribe to the
channel
turn on notifications so you know when
we go live every weekday
and then head to sofi.com so that you
can get an account we can get after it